[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zu sein ließ ihr
habt euch ja einfacher nudel rezepte
gewünscht und was ich bei unserem
italiener super gerne esse ist penne
arrabiata also penne panel mit einer
richtig leckeren scharfen tomatensoße
die zubereitung ist im prinzip super
einfach ich zeige euch trotzdem den
fehler haben sie doch freizeit gewünscht
ich habe ich jetzt die zutaten in
doppelter menge weil wir gleich im
gesamten team essen
ich habe auch noch couscous pfanne von
gestern das heißt dass wir jetzt unser
leckeres mittagessen da drüben steht
vulkan macht den salat ja gleich wird
nämlich hier gemeinsam gegessen und das
gericht ist echt super einfach die
zutaten überschaubar und ich habe es ja
auch immer zu hause weil jetzt gerade
noch keine tomaten saison ist greife ich
auf dosentomaten zurück da solltet ihr
auch wirklich darauf zurückgreifen und
im winter keine tomaten kaufen nur zur
saison
zum einen sehen sie aromatischer und zum
anderen einfach keine importware
hier habe ich kenne nudeln olivenöl
knoblauch und zwiebeln eine scharfe
chili schote tomaten aus der dose salz
und pfeffer und später nämlich noch
etwas petersilie und parmesan bestreuen
das nudelwasser habe ich schon
aufgesetzt also einfach wasser in einem
großen topf das darf gleich schon kochen
hier habe ich einen job für die soße und
kann mein olivenöl darin erhitzen
die zwiebel und knoblauchzehen einfach
fein würfeln
[Musik]
kommen die zwiebelwürfel mit den
knoblauch scheiben in olivenöl und
werden einfach für drei bis vier minuten
schön glasig angebraten
ich nehme jetzt hier eine frische chili
schote ihr könnt aber auch wenn ihr
möchtet einfach chilipulver nehmen und
auch einfach so dazu geben so scharf wie
es eben haben möchte das mache ich ein
bisschen was von der spitze dazu erstmal
nicht zu viel denn ich weiß noch nicht
wie schaffst sie ist okay ich nie ein
bisschen weniger denn wir haben einige
im team nicht so scharf ist
also machen wir es mal so ich hätte
deckel drauf so 34 minuten etwa anbraten
dann helfe ich wohl kaum so lange beim
salat
[Musik]
perfekt sieht es hier aus
da kommen jetzt die tomaten dazu
das ganze wird sich jetzt im prinzip
auch nur noch mit salz und pfeffer
wer weiß was salat ist auch die nächste
wahl hier jetzt die soße die da jetzt
hier sollte auf 5 minuten köcheln und
die zeit nutze ich jetzt auch um die
nudeln machen und nicht ganz al dente
kochen sondern er noch selber
servicetest lassen
also ich koche jetzt nur etwa fünf
minuten und die restliche zeit dürfen
sie dann nämlich in der soße noch könnte
hier kommt derzeit rein die nudeln
kommen hier rein und ich stelle es gab
es jetzt hier auf fünf minuten
[Musik]
die nudeln sind es fertig also wie
gesagt noch richtig bissfest oder
beziehen uns noch gar nicht durch
ich nehme jetzt ein bisschen nudelwasser
raus jetzt die nudeln abgießen
zwink x naja mittagessen zeit da hilft
jeder mit jeder hand zählt jetzt kommen
die nudeln wieder zurück in den topf es
gebe ich hier noch ein bisschen
nudelwasser rein jetzt hier komplett
über die nudel lärm und die soße könnt
ihr wirklich wunderbar vorbereiten
die nudeln dann wirklich nur vorkochen
und stand kurz vor dem essen zusammen
schützen und fertig jetzt muss ich dann
natürlich noch ein bisschen kochen
lassen damit die nudeln jetzt al dente
werden und dann ist unser penne
arrabiata fertig und bei bedarf könnte
jetzt hier das nudelwasser noch zu
gießen wenn ihr braucht und dann
probieren wir es gleich mit etwas
petersilie bestreut
[Musik]
jetzt ist das essen fertig war kam du
kannst probieren morath magst du auch
probieren
nein jetzt probiert doch kommen wie
lecker das aussieht bisschen chili aber
dass chili scharf sehr wohl waren sie
aus dem garten
henne arrabiata cool es ist ja wirklich
wer lieben penne arrabiata weil vor
allem wenn man sich vegan ernährt dann
ist es schwierig wenn man essen geht
weil viele damit noch nichts anfangen
können aber im prinzip kochen viele
schon immer vegan wissens noch nicht
also ein superschnelles gericht im
prinzip bis jetzt auch eher um den
zeitlichen ablauf denn die zubereitung
ist echt ganz einfach die zutaten sind
super easy und wir holen jetzt das ganze
team zum er sonst richtig nudeln nicht
vertrauen
deswegen wirklich nur die saucen
vorbereitung kochen nudeln dann kurz vor
dem 45 minuten lang kochen lassen dann
mit dem nudelwasser also nicht komplett
aber mit etwas nudelwasser in die sauce
geben durchziehen lassen fertig
superlecker ich mache es auch bei mir
noch nie so viele drauf wir machen den
salat noch kurz fertig und dann essen
wir also bis dann viel spaß beim
nachkochen und wenn ihr weitere einfache
nudel rezepte sehen wollt schreibt
einfach in die kommentare
oder was sie als nächstes machen soll
[Musik]